Kevin tenía curiosidad por saber qué tan
rápido crece el pelo.
Se afeitó la cabeza y hizo un seguimiento
del largo de su cabello.
Aquí debería ser "e", perdón.
En la siguiente tabla se muestra la longitud
de pelo de Kevin,
según el número de semanas que
pasaron desde que se lo afeitó.
¿Es proporcional la relación entre el número
de semanas y la longitud del pelo de Kevin?
Bueno, pues este Kevin está loco y decide
tomar medidas extremas para averiguar que
tan rápido crece su pelo, pero bueno...
De la primera a la segunda semana hay un cambio de una semana y pasa de medir 6/7 de cm. a 1cm con 4/7,
1 cm. con 4/7 es lo mismo que pues 1 es 7
entre 7, así que 7 más 4 es 11, serían 11/7,
así que hay un cambio en la longitud de 5/7 de cm.
Ahora, de la segunda a la tercer semana, de
nuevo hay un cambio de una semana,
pero el cambio en la longitud de su pelo
es de 11/7 a 2 con 1/7,
2 con 1/7 es 7 por 2 = 14, más 1 =15, 15/7
por lo tanto hay un cambio de 4/7
en la longitud de su pelo.
Aquí era de 5/7 y acá es de 4/7.
Por lo tanto la relación no puede ser proporcional.